en directo a nos quedamos aquí en la
región porque la defensa del presidente
peruano Pedro Castillo presentó un
recurso ante la Corte Suprema para
anular la denuncia que la fiscalía
presentó contra el mandatario por
presuntamente encabezar una organización
criminal algo que amenaza con quitarle
su inmunidad por eso conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
en la Ciudad de Lima Francisco En qué
sustenta la defensa del presidente Pedro
Castillo la tutela de derechos para
anular la denuncia constitucional contra
el mandatario
Juan buenas noches
Betty Espinoza abogado del presidente
Pedro Castillo afirma que la denuncia de
la fiscalía es inconstitucional porque
viola una resolución de la Corte Suprema
que establece que el mandatario
solamente puede ser acusado
constitucionalmente por el congreso
durante su gobierno por cuatro
cuestiones específicas que establece el
artículo 117 de la Constitución peruana
que son traición a la patria en pedir la
realización de las elecciones disolver
el congreso y bloquear a los organismos
electorales y por tanto sería
inconstitucional que tanto la fiscalía
como el parlamento e impulsa en un
proceso contra el mandatario por la
presunta comisión de los delitos de
organización criminal tráfico
influencias y colusión la defensa
también señala que se estaría
desconociendo a la Constitución peruana
y también
violando un mandato
Zacarías si la Corte Suprema falla a
favor de Pedro Castillo sus opositores
se van a quedar sin argumentos para
sacarlo de la presidencia
Bueno en realidad existen 13
investigaciones en la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales del
parlamento y si es que esto no es
suficiente un grupo de legisladores
están impulsando la tercera moción de
vacancia presidencial contra Pedro
castillo Edward Málaga el legislador que
impulsa el link pagement afirma que ya
tienen alrededor de 100 firmas Mejor
dicho ya tienen alrededor de 100 páginas
y lo que hasta el momento han juntado
son 20 firmas para hacer este que esta
emoción pueda ser programada en el
parlamento lo que se necesita es que el
parlamento junte 87 votos y una vez que
esto suceda se estaría probando una
moción de vacancia presidencial contra
Pedro Castillo